dr jean robert angola says he feels
betrayed not only by new brunswickers
who blamed him for violating covet 19
rules and spreading the virus but also
by facebook for allowing racist
threatening messages to circulate online
facebook must block that
dutch samples first bookcase we must
block that angola alleges the hateful
messages were shared thousands of times
around the world causing him to fear for
his life
his lawsuit pursues punitive damages of
three percent of facebook meta net
profits with the company's net annual
income estimated at more than 86 billion
dollars the claim could be worth a
fortune his lawyers say it's time for
the company to recognize the destruction
and devastation that their actions
caused
going after facebook in court is a
recent development the
tendency of people to see them now as a
viable defendant is new this
constitutional law specialist says it's
partly because of whistleblower francis
haugen who suggested facebook meta is
fixated on profit at the expense of
safety american-based court challenges
have been thwarted by free speech
protections but in canada there are
stronger limits on things like the
racist attacks and alleged threats
hurled at angola that's the very first
section of our constitution that all the
rights in the charter are subject to
reasonable limits including the free
speech rights which almost certainly
will be a key defense that facebook will
put forward in this case others say
angola's case could establish how much
responsibility social media platforms
should take in helping protect and not
damage people's well-being i do think we
need more regulation for social media
companies they hold extraordinary
power in our communities
they're the main way that we engage in
public dialogue in a statement facebook
meta says it doesn't comment on pending
litigation
ross lord global news